To celebrate the release of Tomorrowland,
let's take a look at the many Easter Eggs
and references in Disney's live-action adventure
movie.
Writer and director Brad Bird may have turned
down the opportunity to direct Star Wars Episode
VII because it clashed with his schedule for
making Tomorrowland, but he still managed
to include several Star Wars easter eggs in
his movie.
As Star Wars fans know, those movies have
a little thing for chopping characters arms
or hands off!
So, in a nod to Star Wars, Tomorrowland shows
George Clooney's character, Frank, chopping
off the hand of one of the baddies who's attacking
Britt Robertson's character Casey in Frank's
home.
And there are tons of other Star Wars nods
in the movie too in the Blast From The Past
store.
When Keegan-Michael Key's character, Hugo,
makes his dramatic entrance, you can hear
John Williams' Star Wars theme!
There's a life-size replica of Han Solo in
carbonite from The Empire Strikes Back.
There's a poster of Yoda on the wall.
And there's also a Yoda head on a shelf by
the life-size Stormtrooper.
There's also what looks like an All-Terrain
Scout Transport on the shelf.
And there's an R2-D2.
And did you notice the Millennium Falcon,
the various TIE fighters hanging from the
ceiling, and what looks like a Death Star?
And check out that photo of C3PO & R2-D2.
And let's not forget the bunch of light sabers
on the wall, the Stormtrooper helmet, & Darth
Vader helmet on the shelf, and the illuminated
sign that says Star Wars: The Empire Strikes
Back.
Plus there's a brass lightsaber.
And there's a Stormtrooper figure on the shelf.
And then of course there's all those Star
Wars comic books.
And check out Kathryn Hahn's hair in the movie!
As Ursula Gernsback, she sports Princess Leia-style
buns on the side of her head!
When the movie's art department designed the
1984 version of the jet pack we see in Tomorrowland,
they were influenced by Star Wars, particularly
in its shiny, white metallic finish, which
was inspired by Storm Troopers.
Of course, there's a wealth of other Disney
easter eggs and references too.
There's a photo of Walt Disney, who created
the Tomorrowland section of Disneyland in
1955.
And if you look carefully there are a few
Mickey Mouses hidden about the Blast From
The Past store.
Plus there's an album cover from the soundtrack
of Disney's sci-fi movie from 1979, The Black
Hole!
When Tomorrowland opened it had on show the
sets of the Nautilus from Disney's live-action
sci-fi movie 20,000 Leagues Under The Sea,
which was released in 1954 and was based on
Jules Verne's 19th-century novel of the same
name.
Which is interesting because the look of the
rocket ship in the movie Tomorrowland was
inspired by the design of the Nautilus submarine
from the movie 20,000 Leagues.
And, if you look carefully, you can see a
1965 vinyl record of “Jonny Quest in 20,000
Leagues Under The Sea” in the Blast From
The Past store.
And there's lots of Jonny Quest collectibles
including a Questworld Cyber Copter.
Jonny Quest was an animated sci-fi series
from Hanna-Barbera that started in the mid-60s
and followed a boy's adventures with his scientist
father.
During the World's Fair in the movie, you
can spot The White Rabbit from Disney's 1951
film Alice In Wonderland and the Big Bad Wolf
from Disney's short film Three Little Pigs,
which won the Oscar for Best Animated Short
Film in 1934.
Among the stuff Casey gets back from the local
police is a pack of Beeman's gum, which is
a nod to The Right Stuff, an early 80s movie
about military test pilots in America's first
efforts at manned spaceflight.
In The Right Stuff, pilot Chuck Yeager asks
for some Beeman's gum before a flight.
The same gum also saved the day in the plot
of 1991 Disney movie The Rocketeer, which
brought to life the jet-packed superhero created
by comic book artist Dave Stevens.
When Casey tells Frank that she knows how
gadgets and things work, Frank replies, ‘Well,
zip-a-dee-doo for you.'
That's a reference to the song Zip-A-Dee-Doo-Dah
which featured in Disney's live-action and
animated film Song Of The South and won the
Oscar for Best Original Song in 1947.
Tomorrowland features Disneyland's It's A
Small World ride, which, in the movie, acts
as a portal that takes a young Frank to the
futuristic city of Tomorrowland.
The ride was created especially for the 1964
World's Fair in New York and is made up of
animatronic dolls representing the children
of the world.
The ride's accompanying song It's A Small
World (After All) was written by Robert and
Richard Sherman, who wrote many movie scores
including Mary Poppins and Chitty Chitty Bang
Bang.
The song's optimistic theme of world peace
and international unity was a response to
the Cuban Missile Crisis.
In the movie, as well as It's A Small World
(After All), you can also hear the brothers'
song There's A Great Big Beautiful Tomorrow,
which they wrote for Disney's Carousel of
Progress attraction at the 1964 World's Fair!
As well as writing the score for Tomorrowland,
composer Michael Giacchino also makes a cameo
appearance as the operator of the It's A Small
Word ride at the 1964 World Fair.
Giacchino also composed the music for Tomorrowland
director Brad Bird's movies Ratatouille, The
Incredibles and Mission: Impossible – Ghost
Protocol.
It's interesting that it's a pin that takes
Casey to the city of Tomorrowland as Disney's
theme parks have long sold collectible pins,
and the tradition of Disney Pin Trading has
been around since Disney World's Millennium
Celebration in late 1999.
For the Tomorrowland pin, the movie's design
team used the orange and blue colours of the
1964 World's Fair.
According to director Brad Bird, they wanted
something that felt a bit retro but also classic,
and they used the universal symbol of the
atom like a rising sun in the background.
As for the letter T, they tweaked it a bit
to make it look like a jet pack that's blasting
off.
Among the buildings we see on the skyline
of the city of Tomorrowland is Space Mountain,
the popular ride that opened in 1975 in the
Tomorrowland section of the Magic Kingdom
theme park in Florida's Disney World.
There's also a bunch of references to the
work of Tomorrowland director Brad Bird and
Pixar.
So, there's a Bart Simpson doll hanging from
the shelf in the Blast From The Past store.
Bird was executive consultant on The Simpsons
for many years and directed several episodes
as well as the music video Do The Bartman.
Which is interesting because the Bart doll
in Tomorrowland is wearing the purple mask
of his alter-ego, The Bartman!
Other Simpsons easter eggs include:
a plush toy of the show's comic book superhero
Radioactive Man, whose catchphrase is ‘Up
and atom!'
and a figure of The Collector, who's the villainous
alter-ego of Comic Book Guy and appeared in
Season 11's Treehouse of Horror X.
Brad Bird directed an animated feature film
called The Iron Giant, which is about a young
boy and a robot in the 1950s.
And there's a whole host of The Iron Giant
collectibles, including figures and artwork,
in the Blast From The Past store.
Rock ‘Em Sock ‘Em Robots is a boxing robots
game created in the mid-60s.
It features a Red Rocker and a Blue Bomber
and the idea is for the players to knock the
other robot's head loose!
The Rock ‘Em Sock ‘Em robots have a speaking
cameo in Pixar's Toy Story 2, and can also
be seen among Bob Parr, aka Mr Incredible's
things in The Incredibles, which was written
and directed by Tomorrowland director Brad
Bird!
And there's loads of other pop culture goodies
around the Blast From The Past store too.
And scattered throughout the store there's
more geeky goodies.
Keegan-Michael Key and Kathryn Hahn play Hugo
and Ursula Gernsback.
The name of Key's character is a nod to publisher
Hugo Gernsback who launched Amazing Stories
in 1926, which was the first magazine devoted
to science fiction.
There was actually a 1920s copy of Amazing
Stories in the box labelled 1952 which was
discovered in the Disney archive and sparked
the idea for the movie Tomorrowland.
Interestingly enough, Brad Bird's movie The
Incredibles featured in a much later edition
of Amazing Stories!
There's a lot of Marvin the Martian collectibles,
including toys, a snow globe, folder, and
cups on the counter and the shelves.
And from The Day The Earth Stood Still there's
a life-size version of the robot Gort.
Toy Story 2's Darth Vader-esque evil emperor
Zurg, who's Buzz Lightyear's arch-enemy, also
puts in an appearance in the store.
Plus there's a Strobot Robot 3000, a 1980s
walking robot with flashing red eyes and laser.
And there's a Chief Robotman, a popular Japanese
robot from Yoshiya in the 1960s.
Another robot, this time from the 50s, is
the wind-up Space Robot, Sparky, who walks
and sparks from his mouth!
Plus there's the Lilliput Robot, which is
considered the first tin toy robot made in
late 1930s Japan.
There's a nod to Marvel with the Spider-Man
box that you can make out behind the Chief
Robotman toy in front of it.
Also on the counter we see Omnibot a small
personal robot made in the 1980s, that had
a cassette player, digital clock, the ability
to carry objects including a tray, and much
more!
Thanks to a T-shirt in the shop there's a
nod to Flash Gordon, who was the hero of a
sci-fi comic strip created by artist Alex
Raymond in the 1930s, and the star of a movie
serial, various live-action and animated TV
series, and, of course, the cult 1980 movie
Flash Gordon.
There's a poster for the sci-fi horror movie
Dr Cyclops, about a mad scientist in the Amazon
Jungle who shrinks his colleagues.
The film was directed by Ernest B. Schoedsack
and released in 1940.
Schoedsack also co-directed, with Merian C
Cooper, the 1933 movie King Kong, which you
can see a figure of on the counter.
Now what other easter eggs and references
did you spot in Tomorrowland?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you like this video, please do share it,
hit the thumbs-up button & subscribe for my
movie reviews and interviews!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!